Lose Yourself
a woman who threw away the rule book
Dame Vivian Westwood was fashion royalty
her radical approach brought modern punk
and New Wave fashion to the mainstream
I'll tell you what I think people look
like today they look like they've all
come out of a giant washing machine in
Easy care clothes that are all the most
non-colors and then a few stupid colors
in between
Cheshire born to working-class parents
Westwood went on to become one of the
biggest names in British fashion but it
started with a chance meeting with Sex
Pistols manager Malcolm McLaren with
whom she opened a clothing store on
Kings Road in London
it became a hub of the punk fashion
scene of the 1970s and 1980s with
eccentric designs influenced by sex
bondage and fetish
Westwood changed the way we accepted
what was appropriate to wear in public
no red carpet event is complete without
a Westward this Larger than Life hat
worn by Pharrell Williams to the 2014
Grammys picked up from the Kings Road
Boutique in 1993 Naomi Campbell laughed
off a catwalk moment of Shame after six
inch Vivian Westwood Hills left her flat
on her bottom
but Punk was more than fashion for the
British designer and fashion was more
than just a business we always needed
strong voices to get messages across and
we need people to go too far too often
too strong and I feel like she was one
of those women especially as a woman to
be able to have her behind it with that
much power
in politics Westwood stood against
austerity and fracking when she
announced her support for the green
party in 2015. it was where she said we
could build a true Economy based on real
human values
[Music]
evident supporter of WikiLeaks founder
Julian Assange she visited him several
times during his stay in the Ecuadorian
Embassy
today she is remembered most for her
values
but perhaps musician Boy George puts it
best the great and inspiring Vivian
Westwood he wrote who led us through
Punk and Beyond the Undisputed queen of
British fashion Sadia chowdry Sky News